there's been a fundamental shift in
australian politics and it goes far
beyond electing anthony albanese as the
new labour prime minister
climate
has finally made an impact
becoming one of the issues to swing an
election you saw not just the government
of the day the conservative government
lose but you saw basically a super
majority built around candidates both
from the center and the right and the
left all pushing strong climate action
these candidates include the so-called
teal independence
women who campaigned on issues including
climate change
in traditionally safe liberal party
seats
winning a handful of them there's also
been a strong swing towards the greens
party
i think that this election in australia
is a real watershed you know we have
spent the last decade and perhaps longer
really puddling around in our parliament
and debating whether climate change is
real
with labor's victory the bitter debate
about climate change policies looks
likely to be reset
together we can end the climate wars
together
we can take advantage of the opportunity
for australia to be a renewable energy
superpower
[Applause]
[Music]
more than two years ago the country was
devastated by massive bushfires
blamed on global warming
this year record breaking floods forced
thousands of people to evacuate from
their homes as town after town went
under
so a labor government will be under
pressure to act
fast
it plans to reduce greenhouse gas
emissions by 43 per cent by 2030. a far
more ambitious target than the previous
government
and it's announced it will make coal
miners pay to reduce their carbon
emissions
with this election result australia
could be about to rejoin the global
effort to protect the environment
many would say better late than never
nicole johnston
sky news